bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors nancy pelosi chef des
démocrates au congrès a présenté un
projet de loi permettant de remplacer un
président incapable de remplir ces
fonctions elle dit je ne parle pas de
donald trump
mais on se doute évidemment que c'est
lui qui est visé comment analyser cette
nouvelle offensive de nancy pelosi en
pleine campagne présidentielle est ce
qu'elle peut nuire à donald trump
je ne suis pas certain qu'elle peut
nuire à donald trump je pense qu'on peut
y voir une des dernière initiative en
date d'un parti démocrate qui se
radicalise chaque jour davantage sur le
fond comme sur la forme
ici madame pelosi fait d'une pierre deux
coups d'une part elle s'entend que le
président américain ne serait pas en
état à l'heure actuelle à d'assumer ses
fonctions et d'autre part elle prend
date dans l'hypothèse où monsieur byden
devrait être élu pour justifier pour
légaliser en quelque sorte son
remplacement par ce qu'il est
visiblement de plus en plus attendre je
dirais dans ses capacités
intellectuelles dont ses capacités et
les menteurs et notamment aussi de
déplacement par madame à russe qui est
donc ça sa colistière
donc je crois qu'il faut t'y voir
effectivement peu une preuve énième de
la radicalisation du parti démocrate
est ce qu'une telle commission a à une
chance d'aboutir aux états unis à
l'heure actuelle où aucune
il s'agit de pure communication il n'y a
aucune possibilité juridique d'atteindre
quelques résultats que ce soit et
certainement pas avant l'élection et les
élections en réalité parce qu'il n'ya
pas que la présidentielle du 3 novembre
qu'il faut te voir de la pure
communication politique et comme je le
disais une énième dérive pourrait-on
dire du parti démocrate que plus rien ne
semble arrêter
que ce soit sur le fond ou dans ses
méthodes dans ses velléités de reprendre
le pouvoir
alors comme nancy pelosi a dit que trump
n'étaient pas concernés par la loi
le président américain a lancé une
théorie selon laquelle cet amendement en
servirait à remplacer joe biden en cas
de victoire à la présidentielle par
kamala harris
est-ce que c'est crédible comme théorie
ou est ce que c'est une boutade
non je ne crois pas que c'est une
boutade comme je vous
l'instant je pense que ce faisant elle
aime pdj fait coup double à l aile
elle insulte en quelque sorte le
président américain alors qu'en réalité
il a récupéré du cnid dans un temps
absolument record il donné hier une
interview à la radio chez limbo qui a
duré deux heures que j'ai écouté
d'ailleurs dans son intégralité
vous avez là affaire à quelqu'un qui en
dépit de son âge est en pleine
possession de ses moyens intellectuels
donc oui l'idée par contre que si
monsieur maiden devait être élu étant
donné je dirais la décadence de ses
fonctions intellectuelles à il devra un
jour être remplacé par sa colistière
très populaire dans la population
américaine est une idée réelle
indépendamment de l'initiative ici de
madame pelosi alors donald trump a
rapidement contre attaquer dans un tweet
un ascète à ce projet de loi et qu'une
de nancy pelosi
il a donc je je je cite ces mots un
nancy pelosi la folle jo l'endormi est
ce que c'est c'est quoi c'est dû donald
trump tout craché mais ce que c'est
vraiment digne d'un chef d'état ce
propos on peut dire irrespectueux envers
ses adversaires
il est certain que vous avez là un
vocabulaire qui n'est pas usuel dont
notamment les pays d'europe occidentale
mais de remarque c'est que le surnom de
manuel belletti dans la classe politique
américaine se creuse in and see alors ça
sonne évidemment amusant alors qu'en
français quand vous traduisez par nancy
la folle ça sonne infiniment plus
injurieux et par ailleurs je ne crois
pas que monsieur tron soit le seul
accusé de ce type à 2 d'apple strophe
je me souviens notamment de déclarations
du président russe poutine qui expliqué
qu'ils iraient poursuivre les
terroristes jusque dans les chiottes
donc voilà c'est une façon de parler qui
est imagé mais qui a le mérite en tout
cas d'être clair et je crois dans le cas
du président américain de faire
clairement passer le message qu'il
souhaite faire passer auprès de la
population
faut quand même noter en passant qu'il
est lui-même le chantre d' attaques
incessantes et notamment de la presse et
que donc pour se faire entendre a dit
doit être adopté
un vocabulaire je dirais un parent lui
une communication assez clair assez
direct drieu godefridi merci pour cet
éclairage je rappelle que vous êtes
docteur en philosophie spécialiste des
états unis et auteur de la révolution
trump aux éditions at exquis merci
beaucoup fait plaisir